Intro/Outro
Die neuen Zwanziger.
Die neuen 20ern beeindruckt durch das.
Ein bisschen schon. Man hat ja gewisse ängste wenn etwas ganz Neues beginnt also ein neues Jahrzehnt und man hat aber auch viel Wissen über die anderen Zwanziger die alten Zwanziger die aus dem 20. Jahrhundert.
Bist du verunsichert treibt mich die Angst nicht die Vorfreude.
Doch Vorfreude schon eine gewisse Orientierungslosigkeit die natürlich immer gewisse Gefahren birgt.
Auf.
Die neue Zeit wird vielleicht vieles abstreifen was wir bisher als nicht ganz so gefährlich wahrgenommen haben.
Eventuell erwachen wir auch aus einer großen Grausamkeit. Oder aber es geht weiter wie bisher.
Eventuell erwachen wir aus einer großen Behutsamkeit. Oder aber es geht weiter wie bisher.
Das sind ja so einzelne Themen über die man durchaus mal sprechen könnte gerade wenn man sich fragt wo sonst Zeitungen der sowas steht Du gehst in Kinofilme wird es wenn die neuen Zwanziger schon im Kino behandelt.
Einzelne Themen über die man durchaus mal sprechen könnte gerade wenn man sich fragt wo sonst lesen wir noch eine Zeitung in der so etwas steht.
Du gehst in Kinofilme wird es neuen Zwanziger schon im Kino behandelt.
Werden sicherlich vorkommen Sie wurden ja jetzt schon stärker antizipiert dadurch dass wir eigentlich einen großen Paradigmenwechsel haben.
Hollywood verliert immer mehr an Einfluss auch wenn dort noch die meisten Produktionen her sind die wir so sehen.
Da merkt man schon wie stark Kooperationen mit China geworden sind.
Wir sehen aber auch wie dieser Markt immer globaler wird aber das war schon jetzt ein Thema das man in den 20er Jahren diskutiert hat.
Wir versuchen hier einen großen Brückenschlag Kino ist ein Medium da fällt einem immer auf dass Sachen noch mal tiefschürfende behandelt werden die dann doch in Jahren gemessen zurückliegen.
Kino ist ein Medium da fällt einem immer auf dass die Sache nochmal tiefschürfende behandelt werden die dann doch irgendwie.
Also ein sehr langsames Medium.
Ein sehr langsames Medium. Wenn wir es hier so an der Verkehrstechnik setzen dann.
Wenn wir jetzt hier so an der Podcast Technik sitzen dann könnten wir genausogut sagen Wir sind Fotografen im ganz alten Stile.
Könnten wir genauso gut sind Fotografen im ganz eigenen Stile und irgendwie irgendein Gerät auch und spricht da irgendetwas was stimmen konserviert.
Man hat irgendein Gerät auf den Tisch und spricht halt in irgendetwas was Stimme konserviert.
Man kann das unendlich lang ziehen. Gerade Podcaster ist die lange Form zurück. Trotzdem kann man über die Sachen lange reden die gestern passiert sind.
Man kann das unendlich lange ziehen.
Wie lange vor und zurück. Trotzdem kann man über die Sachen lange reden. Gestern passiert das ist so ungewöhnlich dass es in anderen Rahmen schon mal als Ausbeutung des Marxismus.
Das ist so ungewöhnlich dass es in anderem Rahmen schon mal als eine Ausbeutung des Marxismus benannt. Man holt sich.
Bzw. sehr marxistisch. Man hat hier die Produktionsmittel in der Hand Man ist nicht angewiesen auf den großen Sender auf den Reichen Verleger der einem irgendetwas ermöglicht nämlich das Publizieren,
sondern wir können es hier zusammen machen.
Hier.
Direkt für die Hörer Wir brauchen keine Intermediäre dazwischen.
Das ist einfach da haben wir beide auf vielen Ebenen schon mitbekommen das ist eine spektakuläre Technologie.
Wir beide.
Du machst ansonsten die Filme Analyse kümmert sich also genau um dieses andere Medium das so behäbig aber dann ebenso tiefschürfenden daherkommt.
Den Wohlstand für alle. In vielen anderen Formaten.
Und ich schreibe auch im Gegensatz zu dir ja doch noch relativ häufig für Zeitungen.
Aber du hast ja der Zeitung eigentlich ganz Adieu gesagt oder es wird sich irgendwie einen Schlussstrich zu ziehen langsam ausklingen zu lassen.
Ja es baut sich irgendwie an den Schlussstrich zu ziehen und es nicht langsam ausgeliehene zu lassen wie du das machst denn das Ende ist klar.
Die Frage ist nur Nimmt man selber in die Hand oder nutzt man auch Gelegenheiten solange sie sich bieten was nicht heißt dass ich weniger schreibe.
Was nicht heißt dass sie weniger.
Bei mir mündet das dann halt auch in einem sehr langsamen Medium jetzt wieder im Buch Republik.
Das kommt dann halt einfach im Sommer und wurde angefangen im vorletzten Sommer Ich bleibe ich dem Schreiben verbunden allerdings nicht in der Zeitung denn das ist meine Frage die da bleibt warum und das Besondere der Frage Ist man muss ich nicht mehr beantworten.
Sommer oder eingefangene.
Sich mit dem Schreiben verbunden allerdings nicht in der Zeitung. Denn warum habe ich meine Frage bleibt Warum muss ich mich in der Warnton.
Warum lesen wir alle keine Zeitungen aus egal eigentlich.
Dieser Podcast ja nicht ein einziger Podcast sondern du hast dich da schon sehr etabliert mit dem Aufwachen Podcast.
Genau. üblicherweise mache ich mit Thilo den Podcast der sich nun wiederum auch einem anderen Medium zuwendet nämlich dem Fernsehen das ein bisschen in der Schwebe hängt also immer mal die,
mittelfristig relevanten Sachen nimmt und dann in einem Medium das eigentlich für sehr viel langsamere arbeiten konzipiert wurde aber sehr viel schneller arbeitend Filme herzustellen die am Morgen noch nicht geplant wurden aber am Abend schon gesendet werden müssen.
Über diese ganzen Merkwürdigkeiten die da im Resultat entstehen ist ja nachzuhören.
Hier versuchen wir wieder eine Lücke zu füllen aber eben auch so wie du es eben begonnen hast man weiß nicht genau was die neuen Zwanziger bedeuten.
Wir können sehr viel über die alten Zwanziger reden also über die 1920er Jahre und wir werden da auch sehr viel darüber erfahren wir werden jetzt gleich so ein Fundament legen.
Wir wissen trotzdem nicht genau Ist es jetzt Zuversicht oder ist es Angst die uns treibt.
Wenn man sich die alten 1820er anschaut das ist jetzt hundert Jahre her.
Menschen die die 20er Jahre bewusst miterlebt haben haben sowohl den ersten und zweiten Weltkrieg Faschismus Wirtschaftskrise Existenznot und alles mitbekommen und haben trotzdem irgendwie ihr Leben gemeistert.
Total erstaunlich und viele Sachen die in dieser wie soll man sagen etwas wilderen glamourösen extravaganten aber doch politisch ruhigen Phase zumindest in der ersten Hälfte der zwanziger Jahre.
Viele Grundsteine die damals gelegt werden prägen uns ja bis heute.
In der Kunst in der Technik die Medienwelt ist eigentlich so wie wir sie heute kennen noch sehr nah dran auch an den 20er Jahren nun nicht mehr dreimal täglich aber immerhin noch einmal täglich,
Fortschritte von denen wir heute noch profitieren.
Nur ein Produkt.
Du bist gleich wieder beim Film. Aber noch hat sich.
Hat sich da gegründet mit seiner Firma 1923 da ging es los mit.
Der 21.
Das war noch eine stumme Filmwelt. Es sind aber auch Fragen philosophischer oder theologischer Natur die aufkommen die uns heute wieder begegnen.
Sind aber auch Fragen philosophischer oder theologischer Natur die aufkommen die uns heute wieder begegnen zum Beispiel stellt man sich natürlich nachdem das Kaiserreich zusammengebrochen ist die Frage Ist die Demokratie jetzt das passende System.
Zum Beispiel stellt man sich natürlich nachdem das Kaiserreich zusammengebrochen ist die Frage von Demokratie jetzt.
Eine Frage die sich jetzt wieder einige Stellen mit Blick auf den Aufstieg von China und den Aufstieg Indiens. Und man fragt sich Ist die Demokratie zu langsam wenn man sich die Lage anschaut mit dem Klima.
Wieder einige Stellen mit Blick auf den Aufstieg von China und den Aufstieg Indiens mantraartig die Demokratie zu langsam. Wenn man.
Ja.
Damals hat man eine wie soll man sagen Monarchie kann man nicht ganz sagen eine kaiserliche Hoheit damit hat man den Kaiser vom Hof gejagt.
Einen Weltkrieg durchlebt und hat festgestellt Es war der 9. November.
Es steht ja im Geschichtsbuch an einem Tag oder gleich zweimal die Republik ausgerufen Republik war das große neue Ding Republik wurde dann recht früh recht eng an Demokratie und Marktwirtschaft geknüpft.
Man hat sich über diesen Dreiklang die ganze Welt erschlossen das ganze christliche Weltbild macht die Welt Untertan,
hat man damals in die DNA der modernen Welt einprogrammiert Die Weltbevölkerung ist von zwei Millionen auf acht Millionen angewachsen.
Darüber jetzt sind wir am Ende von dieser Entwicklung angekommen Wir wissen zwar seit 40 Jahren dass das Wachstum Grenzen hat aber wir wissen jetzt wo die Grenzen sind nämlich vor allem bei Ressourcen.
Und jetzt stoßen wir an diese Grenzen und wir müssen uns wirklich die Frage stellen dauert überlebt die Demokratie die Form von Republik wie wir sie haben eigentlich die neuen Zwanziger Jahre.
Oder laufen wir da nicht in die Gefahr völlig blind.
Das wäre dann ganz schlecht aber vielleicht sind tatsächlich in einzulaufen von denen wir die Lösung noch nicht kennen.
Man kann ja zumindest über die Ursachen reden.
Beziehungsweise die Lösung nicht durchsetzen können das ist ja ein interessantes Phänomen.
Der Staatsrechtler Carl Schmitt 1922 schon publiziert hat bis heute sehr einflussreich ist die geistesgeschichtliche Lage des Parlamentarismus.
Dort sagt er das Parlament neigt zur ewigen Diskussion keine Entscheidungen gefällt werden für die Diktatur.
Und er war auch derjenige gewesen der Hitler paktiert hat.
Stellt man sich genau diese Frage. Es gibt eine extreme Pluralität eine viel größere als wir sie heute kennen.
Positionen die vertreten sind auch die in der Mitte der Gesellschaft.
Die Parlamente als quasselt buhten zu disqualifizieren begann recht früh nach ihrer Erfindung.
Gleichzeitig wurden überall quasi Buden eingerichtet die vielleicht gar nicht entscheidend sind.
Gründung von Universitäten und so weiter und so fort Der Hörsaal.
Heute stellt man uns ganz konkret die Frage in welchen Hörsälen darf gesprochen werden.
Es gibt einige Diskussionen darüber und natürlich darf die ursprüngliche Bude noch mitentscheiden oder wird sie wie jeder andere.
Also erkennen wir noch einen Unterschied von einem Bundestag werden jetzt Wahlen in Großbritannien wo eine der Gründungs Vorbild Republiken,
tatsächlich ihr Parlament einfach entmachtet indem sich der Premierminister im Vorfeld der Wahl von jedem Kandidaten eine Unterschrift geben lässt nach der Wahl bin ich dein Herrscher und wenn ich sage er geht Brexit dann wirst du hier mitmachen.
Ansonsten habe ich von dir unterschrieben dass du dann diesen Parlamentssitz auch freigibt für diejenigen die mir da folgen hatte das Parlament schon entmachtet.
In Europa ist es so ein bisschen gegenläufig. Sehr viele Sachen laufen derzeit in Europa über das Parlament auf der anderen Seite ist da nichts in Stein gemeißelt Wir haben eine neue Kommissionspräsident hin.
Wie soll man sagen als neue Regentin. Eigene Themen setzt in einem Maße wie wir es vorher noch nicht erlebt haben wenn auch erst mal ein Thema Klima dem wir alle uns irgendwie beipflichten.
Das ist ein wichtiges Thema aber sie hat damit ein Thema gesetzt bei dem sie über das Parlament hinausgehen kann.
Wenn man jetzt nochmal nicht nur beim Parlamentarismus und so weiter,
oder beim Film angesprochen zurückblickt diese neuen 20ern die wir jetzt starten kann man auch geruhsamer betrachten Man muss wahrscheinlich nicht gleich so alarmistisch rangehen denn in den alten Zwanzigern,
gab es mehrere Gründungen nicht nur Disney sondern auch die Lufthansa,
und damit das Mobilitäts Versprechen unserer Zeit,
über den individuellen Verkehr hinaus Wir müssen uns neuen Sitznachbar,
erdulden und dann können wir überall auf der Welt sein diese Idee kam damals.
Man könnte dann sagen es wurde dann demokratisiert über die Preise sollte ich zur Verfügung stehen.
Rewe wurde damals gegründet also die Idee von Versorgung durch die letzte Meile macht der Kunde selbst.
Er steht vor dem Regal und entscheidet was er kauft man bekommt schon viel nach Hause geliefert aber einkaufen geht man immer noch selbst das wird sich in diesem neuen Jahrzehnt auch sehr wandeln wahrscheinlich Geschichten wie Rewe werden sich,
ganz anders ergeben da wird man nicht so rausgehen aus dem Jahrzehnt wie rein.
Und neben Lufthansa und Rewe ist es auch die Arbeitslosenversicherung und wir haben darüber beispielsweise ganz neue Menschenbilder die sich so eingeschlichen hatten.
Mit der Arbeitslosenversicherung eine Idee von jemand kümmert sich um dich wenn du aus der Arbeitswelt herausfällt bist du noch nicht ganz raus weil der Staat immer noch sich um dich kümmert und dass man nur versichern Natur.
Heute reden wir nicht mal von der Versicherung sondern von der Agentur also von Agenten handelnden Menschen die dich als Kunden ansehen und dich auf einem Arbeitsmarkt sehen auch wenn du gerade nicht Arbeit ist.
Diese Verknüpfung von dem Einzelnen und dem Staat die wir heute immer noch als bürgerlich pflegen so benennen das ist auch eine Idee aus den 20er Jahren wie so vieles.
Was auch daran liegt dass.
Der Soziologe Siegfried Kracauer diesen Angestellten ein Buch mit dem gleichnamigen Titel zeigt wie sich dadurch auch die Stadtbevölkerung ganz klar verändert.
Auch für Frauen etwas Emanzipatorisches hat. Allein die Schreibmaschine,
sorgt dafür dass plötzlich ganz viele Angestellte weibliche Angestellte die Sekretärinnen arbeiten was dann auch Thema in ganz vielen Romanen der 20er Jahre ist.
Und diese Angestellten pflegen auch eine eigene Kultur in der Freizeit beispielsweise gehört der Sport dazu gehören Kulturvereine dazu aber da gehört auch,
die massenmediale Unterhaltung dazu und auch etwas was sehr erstaunlich ist das hat Marcel Mauss der französische Ethnologe beobachtete er ging durch New York und sah dort Frauen in einer gewissen Weise spazieren.
Einige Wochen später in Paris und merkte dass dort Frauen ganz genau so gehen fragte sich Warum ist das so eine Internationalisierung der Massenkultur.
Man hat dort in einem Film gesehen dass Frauen so gehen und dann macht man das in Paris.
Und so ist es dann auch mit dem Angestellten Milieu das so sehr schnell eine eigene Kultur die sehr urban ist entwickelt.
Diese Internationalisierung von Lebensstilen über schon angesprochen die Lufthansa,
über die Standardisierung von Ernährung Breve über die Standardisierung des Films Disney alle diese Organisationen getriebenen.
Standardisierung Metamorphosen Homogenisierung zumindest der westlichen Welt.
Die ist eigentlich hochinteressant. Du sagst das völlig zu recht glaube ich dass diese Technik Getriebenheit.
Heute haben wir es abgeschafft. Mittelwelle und Langeweile Wir haben nur noch die ultra Kurzwelle und die es auch so ist das ist die Zeit der Zwanziger Das war das Internet der Zwanziger der alten Zwanziger.
Man hat plötzlich Radio gehabt Stummfilmen wie schon angesprochen der Farbfilm kam ja auch noch in den Zwanzigern nämlich 1920 und 1926 schon ich war ein bisschen überrascht hatte,
John Logie Bert oder wie auch immer ausgesprochen wird den ersten mechanischen Fernsehern vorgestellt.
Gleichzeitig gab es die erste Internationale Funkausstellung auch in den Zwanzigern und 1928 hat die Reichspost die Bild Funkübertragung erprobt.
Und wenn wir heute sagen Gott sei Dank haben wir Internet kann man sagen Gott sei Dank hatten die damals auch so eine Art Internet.
Es hat noch nicht so viel mit Digitalisierung zu tun aber mit Elektrifizierung doch schon.
Und wenn man der deutschen Soziologie nach Dirk Becker und so weiter dann sagen die es hat einige Brüche gegeben aber ob die Digitalisierung ein war wenn dann doch die Elektrifizierung.
Und damit hat man wieder so einen Bogen schlagen aus 100 Jahren Menschheitsgeschichte von den 1920ern zu diesen neuen 20ern.
Wenn nicht genau wissen wie viel Entwicklung geht jetzt einfach solide weiter.
Man kann sich auch noch mal hundert Jahre Fernsehen vorstellen liegt heute irgendwie nahe gleichzeitig ist aber das Smartphone auch irgendwie da.
Und ob YouTube und Tic Tac einfach nur in der Digitalisierung von Fernsehen sind oder doch ein bisschen mehr und anderes. Das wird sich dann herausstellen.
Jedenfalls haben wir heute noch einmal mehr fremde Stimmen im Ohr durch Podcaster,
als damals aber es fängt damit an Man muss sich vorstellen,
vor der Erfindung des Radios vor dem Grammophon hat man immer nur die Stimmen gehört aus seiner direkten Umgebung und dann in den 20er Jahren hat sich das viel stärker durchgesetzt dann kam mit dem Film auch noch nicht nur eine körperlose Stimme,
ins Ohr sondern auch eine die direkt mit dem Körper verbunden war.
Das war 1929 der Jazz Singer der erste Tonfilm.
Das deutsche Pendant zu dieser Entwicklung ist der blaue Engel mit Marlene Dietrich 1929 dort gedreht mit Emil Jannings.
Da hört man dann eine Frau singen Ich bin von Kopf bis Fuß auf Liebe eingestellt was natürlich auch darauf verweist dass wir hier,
ein anderes Rollenbild plötzlich vorfinden Technisierung und Urbanisierung sorgt natürlich auch für eine Form der Emanzipation eine Loslösung aus der familiären Herkunft aus,
dem tradierten aus dem Patriarchat wenn man so will.
Neue Frauen in den 20er Jahren und gerade jetzt erleben wir wieder die Umbrüche die De-Industrialisierung ist weit fortgeschritten.
Das macht körperliche Arbeit immer mehr zumindest in der westlichen Welt obsolet.
Damit verändern sich aber auch die eigenen Wahrnehmung von Körper.
Das heißt aber nicht dass der Körper unwichtig wird sondern er wird mehr ein Luxus den Fitness haben wir ja schon eine ganze Weile.
Über 100 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland sind in Fitnessstudios angemeldet und wir werden in den 20er Jahren die Prognose wagen.
Es wird nicht weniger werden sondern es wird noch stärker zunehmen wir werden auch immer mehr Männer haben die zu Kosmetik greifen die zur Schönheitschirurgie greifen.
Vielleicht entsteht aber auch eine Gegenbewegung auf Seiten der Frauen die sagen Wir haben uns jetzt,
100 Jahre stark an der Massenkultur orientiert an Filmen und so weiter in unseren ästhetiken Jetzt produzieren wir was Neues oder ist durch so etwas wie,
andere Körperbilder sehr junge Körperbilder vermittelt werden.
Das wird sehr entscheidend sein das zu beobachten und dann immer wieder Verbindungen herzustellen denn wie gesagt Es ist eine Zeit des Umbruchs. Aber auch damals schon.
Tick tack bringt den jungen Körper plötzlich in Stellung wie wir es uns vorher im Internet nicht vorstellen konnten weil das Silicon Valley doch immer so eine gewisse Vorbehalte hatte,
Körpern gegenüber sowieso sexualisierten Körpern erst recht und jungen Körpern obendrein YouTube prügelt das ja gerade noch mal durch mit ordentlichem Bannern und auch rechtlichen Vorschriften.
Diese Form allerdings überhaupt auf Körper Bezug zu nehmen kann man natürlich sagen Ja das war dieses Argument von Schirrmacher was er auch aus der Literatur gezogen hat.
Der Mensch wurde von Arbeit befreit und der Körper war noch immer da und man fragte sich Was mache ich eigentlich mit meinem Körper. Und plötzlich haben alle angefangen Sport zu treiben.
In dem Moment wo der Körper entlastet ist belastet man ihn aber so wie man sie eben selber will und dann diesen ästhetischen Gesichtspunkten unter viel von dem was jetzt in dieser Nachkriegszeit entstand die Fitness Welle.
Die Idee Ich habe einen Feierabend Was mache ich eigentlich. Ich könnte mich ja Vergnügen. Es ist vor allem ein körperliches Vergnügen.
Reines geistiges Vergnügen es nicht. Das erleben wir jetzt gerade alle am Smartphone.
Also einfach nur geistig abschalten und sich treiben lassen es reicht nicht der Körper muss mitgenommen werden und vieles von dem was wir bis heute erlebt haben.
In dieser Ruhephase nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg ist eigentlich Renaissance der 20er Jahre,
nicht nur die Arbeitslosenversicherung sondern auch überhaupt der geregelte Arbeitstag mit anschließendem Feierabend ist eine Errungenschaft aus dieser Zeit.
Da kann man dann verschiedene Sachen nachlesen wie z.B.
Die Geschichte der Leibes Ertüchtigung oder auch einfach der Freude am Dasein.
Das schlägt sich dann auch darin nieder dass man den Körper überhaupt erst mal kurz und klein schlägt in der Kunst.
Wir haben Dadaismus und Surrealismus aus dieser Zeit wo man ja auch diese Körperlichkeit sogar begrifflich irgendwie niederschlägt.
Die Emanzipation ist auch eine Sache die hat in den Zwanzigern angefangen dort niedergeschlagen gleich in medialen Bildern.
Die wilden Zwanziger das sind auch Frauen zu sehen die einfach nur Männer in Berlin sondern es ist da vor allem die Frau die sich Geltung verschafft.
Und wir haben über so eine neue Möglichkeit über neue Freizeitmöglichkeiten,
und neue Angebote an Menschen über die Lohnarbeit hinaus haben wir überhaupt so eine Idee von biografischer Gestaltung.
Menschen nahmen plötzlich ihr Leben selbst in die Hand und auch wenn es mal mit der gegenwärtigen Arbeitsumgebung in der man sich befand nicht geklappt hat dann hat man einfach Anschluss gefunden und diesen Bogen Schläger hat man dann irgendwie bewältigt.
Die Gründung der Volkshochschule fällt auch auf die 20er Jahre.
Es ist ganz erstaunlich wie reichhaltig so ein kurzer kurzer Moment ist zwischen zwei Ersten Weltkrieg und der totalen Wirtschafts Katastrophe zwar gerade mal elf Jahre Zeit um diesen Grundstein für hundert Jahre Geschichte zu legen.
Von allem was wir jetzt schon Ansprachen und noch so unendlich viel mehr was eben auch noch eine Rolle spielt.
Deswegen lasst uns zum Ende nochmal über Weltbilder reden. Ich war ganz erstaunt da wenn man einfach die Zwanziger als Suchbegriff mal bei youtube eingibt und sich treiben lässt.
Was ich nicht wusste ist wie sehr die Menschen vor den 1920er Jahren nicht wussten in welcher Welt sie eigentlich leben.
Es gab keine Bilder von außen. Es war noch niemand auf dem Mond noch nicht mal jemand im Weltraum.
Niemand ist besonders hoch geflogen Erdkrümmung sehen war schon den Küstenbewohner vorbehalten.
Man wusste im Grunde gar nicht genau wo man ist man hat einfach nur ein Sternenhimmel gesehen dass es einmal einen Urknall gab war einer Idee die damals propagiert wurde.
Heute wissen wir ja wir wissen zwar immer noch nicht genau wie sie es damit.
Aber es ist die einzige Theorie die bis heute überstanden hat.
Aus dem Urknall erwächst diese Idee der Expansion des Weltraums.
Dass sich Sachen überhaupt fortentwickeln war vorher unklar.
Die Routine stellte den Rahmen des Alltags her.
Man ist in den Krieg gegangen weil jemand gesagt hat Wir gehen jetzt mal in den Krieg.
Aber dass man ein Krieg auch führen kann mit einer Ideologie dahinter und die Menschen dann umso fanatischer.
Das sind alles so Geburten der 20er Jahre.
Also muss man dann auch sagen Faschismus.
Ideologien waren selbst unbekannt bis dahin und dann kam gleich eine der schrecklichsten wie wir heute wissen.
Verbunden dann auch einmal mit einer Traumatisierung durch den Krieg aber mit einer zugleich eintretenden Romantisierung des Krieges als letztes Abenteuer.
Wenn man nur an einen Autor wie Ernst Jünger denkt der 120 schon seinen Kriegstagebuch In Stahlgewittern veröffentlicht dann 922 den Essay schreibt der Kampf als inneres Erlebnis,
eben das Dasein nur dann wirklich spüren lässt wenn man eine Begegnung hat und.
Möglicherweise dabei sterben muss getötet wird aber auch dies wird dann quasi als ein Genuss beschrieben.
Es ist erstaunlich dass das zum Teil einfach nur mit so einer Philosophie aufgeladen wird zugleich aber auch möglicherweise mit einer faschistischen Ideologie wie es dann geschehen ist.
Da wurde ja dann sehr viel auch aus den 20er Jahren in den 30er Jahren noch einmal in ganz anderer Form vereinnahmt.
Das ist natürlich der Unterschied zu heute dass wir nicht diese Kriegstraumata in irgendeiner Weise haben diese Kriegserfahrung die Menschen die uns hier zuhören haben,
nicht einen Krieg erlebt wie das die Menschen getan haben die in den 20er Jahren gelebt haben.
Aber was man vielleicht doch spüren kann ist durch diese große Orientierungslosigkeit eine gewisse Sehnsucht auch nach,
ernsthaftem im Ernstfall nach einer gewissen Härte und die ist mitunter hochgefährlich wenn man sich anschaut was neurechten Strömungen gedacht wird und wie genau an solche Denkweisen Ideologien wieder angeknüpft wird.
Ja also Menschen die auch heute noch faschistischen Ideologien anhängen,
kann man nicht einfach nur unterstellen die wurden irgendwie von einem herrschenden ausgetrickst sondern diese Ideologie aktiviert irgendwas in den Menschen selbst und sei es der Sinn des Lebens als die finale Katastrophe oder wie auch immer,
diese Dramatik die in den 20ern,
wenn man sieht dass sich viele Menschen vergnügen und man vielleicht nicht Teil dieser Realität ist die da in einem wächst das sieht man auch heute wieder.
Wir haben in diesen 20er Jahren in diesen 29 Jahren die größten Probleme werden Einsamkeit sein Armut Armut und Einsamkeit zusammen das Alter das noch besonders einsam macht.
Die ersten Erkenntnisse sind da inwieweit Einsamkeit sich auch körperlich niederschlägt bis hin zur Demenz und befördert.
Das sind alles so ist es im Grunde ein großer Kosmos.
Man sollte nicht zu früh irgendwelche Sachen verstehen Nur weil man einen Film gut fand in dem irgendwie Dominic Cummings nochmal dargestellt wurde wie er die Briten vorführt.
Als unser Brexit Nation macht sondern da steckt dann immer mehr dahinter weshalb wir diesen Brückenschlag.
Der bietet sich natürlich an die 1920er und die 2020 die hundert Jahre sind allerdings auch ausgedacht hätte man an einen Kalender hätte es halt nicht so gepasst aber in dem Fall passt irgendwie.
Aber es ist neu deswegen die neuen Zwanziger. Es wird sich die Geschichte nicht wiederholen.
Das können wir glaube ich sagen Wir werden nur gewisse Parallelen aufzeigen können und wir werden aber dann auch sehr schnell merken wie es ganz neue Amts Abzweigungen gibt.
Auch dadurch dass die Möglichkeit entsteht dass ständig dann doch etwas ganz ganz Neues noch einmal eintritt was alles verändern kann sei es nun ein technischer Fortschritt oder irgendein historisches Ereignis.
Genau. Es geht rein um Methodologie. Wenn wir feststellen dass Radio und die Langweile und die Nutzung dieser physikalischen Gegebenheiten.
Das Radio.
Die 20er Jahre irgendwie verändert dann sagen wir nicht das passiert noch nochmal sondern wir sehen daran wie sehr solche kleinen technischen Fortschritte wirklich kleine technischen Fortschritte.
Sondern wir sehen daran wie sehr technisch.
Heute ist es nicht mehr das Belegen von irgendwelchen Wellen mit Informationen die man mitliefert sondern heute ist es vielleicht wirklich einfach nur eine App die besonders attraktiv auf dem menschlichen Auge ankommt die das Gehirn nochmal besonders massiert.
Nicht.
Besonders attraktiv auf dem menschlichen Auge ankommt. Besonders massiert oder etwas relativ unsichtbares wie die Veränderungen eines Algorithmus der plötzlich die Denkweise ganz vieler Menschen.
Z.B. in etablierten Systemen. Facebook ist nicht mit einem Newsfeed auf die Welt gekommen aber irgendwann war da und hat komplett Facebook übernommen.
Apple war keine Telefonfirma aber irgendwann war das.
Apple war zehnmal so groß wie vorher nur noch Telefone hergestellt. Diese kleinen Ideen schlagen sich irgendwo nieder und reißen die ganze Welt mit sich und es geht heute natürlich noch viel schneller als damals denn ja,
das Radio wurde irgendwann erfunden aber bis zum Volksempfänger hat es eine Weile gedauert.
Das ist heute natürlich anders. Eine Milliarde Menschen zu erreichen dafür hat tektonisch genau zwei Jahre gebraucht und 1,5 Milliarden Werbebudget. Und zack war das Ziel erreicht.
In der Ansicht sind es immer diese Rahmen in der Soziologie würde man sagen man nimmt sich so ein großes Pussycat teil.
Puzzle ein großes Puzzle bilden Panorama und versucht die einzelnen Puzzleteile voneinander zu unterscheiden.
Das Puzzle zu zerlegen Man hätte es dann mit. Und das weiß man im Vorfeld nicht.
Artefakten zu tun kann Technologie sein kann eine neue Idee sein eine Idee die die Technik unterstützt.
Eine Technologie die aufgrund einer Idee entsteht wie auch immer es wird relativ selten irgendeine politischer Zufall sein oder so.
Sie ist sehr häufig einfach eine Idee oder eine technische Entwicklung die irgendwas vorantreibt und dann hat man es mit und da bin ich sehr gespannt weil wir in diese Methodologie irgendwie selbst entwickeln müssen aber im Grunde auch nicht so hochtrabend damit umgehen müssen.
Man hat es dann mit latenten Strukturen zu tun.
Latent ist einfach der Gegenbegriff zum Manifest. Das heißt man sieht sie nicht.
Man kann über sie reden aber man kann Indizien gibt es vielleicht Beweise wird es nie geben sondern man kann einfach nur Vermutungen anstellen darüber und man stellt fest dass diese Form der Suche relativ selten stattfindet.
Wenn man sich heute überlegt man hätte ökonomischer Verantwortung für eine Zeitung wie baut man sie eigentlich so zurück dass der Leser es möglichst nicht merkt dann nimmt man alles raus was mit Nachdenken zu tun hatten lässt alles drin was mit den Fakten von gestern zu tun hat und dann hat man eine,
Zeitung die besteht aus dem Kanzler Zitate des Vortages und nachgedacht wird dann dann nicht mehr.
Deswegen ist diese Art der Nutzung von Produktionsmitteln die man einfach in der Hand hat in dem Fall ein Aufnahmegerät ein Grammophon oder umgedreht einen Fotografen.
Warum eigentlich keine Wiedergabe ohne Aufnahme ist.
Über die Idee ein Podcast zu machen macht immer Spaß und ist kinderleicht.
Das ist auch noch etwas tiefer liegende Entscheidung. Es ist einfach Erstens im Gespräch und zweitens im Gespräch zu klären und nicht etwa schriftlich.
Ich glaube wir können diese Latenzen auch nur wirklich begreifen wenn man sie sich einander erzählt.
Wenn man versucht ein bisschen abzuschleifen auf etwas hinzuweisen was man vielleicht nicht gleich fassen kann aber man kann sich in einem Gespräch viel besser annähern und glaube was wir vorhaben mit diesem Podcast.
Wir flanieren eigentlich durch dieses 20.
Jahrhundert Wir schauen nach rechts nach links wir bleiben stehen gehen wieder einen Schritt weiter laufen vielleicht auch hin und wieder wo es nötig ist um uns selbst zu orientieren.
Hoffentlich auch ein bisschen Orientierung zu geben und dadurch zu sagen es könnte auch ganz gut werden.
Ja
Oder gehst du ganz pessimistisch rein.
Ich will ja nicht die Hoffnung nehmen. Ich finde auch man sollte erst mal grundsätzlich hoffnungsvoll rangehen allerdings sollte man sensibel mit den drohenden Gefahren umgehen und die sind nun reichlich vorhanden.
Dieses Bild des flanierenden finde ich ganz hervorragend denn wo flaniert man eigentlich.
Na klar auf der großen Treppe zwischen dem teuren Theater Erlebnis und der Welt in die man zurückgeworfen wird dann zwar in dem Moment als anderer Mensch nach dem Stück aber man flaniert sozusagen aus,
dem Safe Space wo man dem Regisseur vertraut dass er das ganze Ding zumindest als Schauspiel sicher über die Bühne bringt.
Flaniert man wieder zurück auf die Straße und dann muss man hoffen dass die U-Bahn noch fährt jetzt erst wieder zum Jahresende erlebt als ich hier im Schauspiel Frankfurt Tintenherz gesehen habe.
Einfach sensationell mit Kindern ins Theater zu gehen und danach zurück in die Welt zu treten vor allem weil dieses Theaterstück dann 32 aufhört.
Es hat mich um neun begonnen und dann stehe ich draußen und muss die Kinder sicher zurück zur Schule bringen.
Gefahren lauern überall deswegen die Gefahren sind da der Optimismus natürlich auch.
Man sollte ihn natürlich begründen. Das alte Schirrmacher Wort Urteile.
Ja aber bitte nur begründet keine Meinung.
Wir werden es allerdings wenn sehr viel Meinung zu tun haben denn das ist das Geschäft das Social Media den man mit Podcasts auch ein bisschen begegnen kann.
Aber es ist für mich ein bisschen Angst vor dem neuen Jahrzehnt zu wissen was ich die nächsten zehn Jahre tun werde nämlich regelmäßig treffen und über die Zeit reden in der wir jetzt gerade leben.
Wir machen es jetzt zehn Jahre lang mindestens einmal im Monat.
Es ist also ein Riesenprojekt.
Die 2000 20er Jahre werden lang werden nämlich zehn Jahre lang,
und jeden Monat kehren wir einmal die Sache dieses Monats zusammen und zwar vor allem die auf die es ankommt und die in der tagespolitischen journalistischen oder wie auch immer Auseinandersetzung nicht stattfinden weil sie,
in dieser Zwischenwelt stattfinden.
Ja es war gestern aber Merkel war auch gestern. Oder wie auch immer der nächste Bundeskanzler heißt und ja war schon relevant aber ich bin Filmemacher. Mein Film kommt dann in drei Jahren.
Also wie vorhin schon angesprochen Parkas erlauben in langer Form hochaktuell zu sein und mit hochaktuell meine ich,
einfach die letzten vier Wochen rekapitulieren lassen dass es ein großes Angebot der Technik das wir einfach nutzen.
Da beginnen die 20er Jahre finde ich sehr optimistisch. Man kann das nämlich jetzt machen es gab sehr viele Jahrzehnte in denen das nicht so ging und damit meine ich alle Jahrzehnte bis zur Jahrtausendwende.
Erst danach war es überhaupt möglich das so zu machen denn Elektrifizierung und Digitalisierung bedeutet.
Man spricht nicht einfach nur sondern man kann jetzt auch zuhören Alle Welt ist Podcast Hörer und Hörerinnen und manche nehmen dann auch daran teil.
Wir freuen uns da sehr drauf. Das wird eine ganze launige Sache und es wird vor allem das ist mir auch nochmal wichtig anzumerken Es wird vor allem ein Projekt vor Ort.
Wir brauchen in dem Moment auch wie wir es hier gerade sitzen kein Internet.
Wir sitzen uns gegenüber das muss man vielleicht dazusagen. Wir sitzen.
Wir sitzen uns gegenüber und es ist ja kein Internet an Wolfgang hat einen ganz kleinen Zettel.
Einheitsbrei,
und ich habe ja digitales Papier. Es ist kein Internet gewesen um mir ein paar Notizen zu machen.
Ich habe ja digitales Papier aber es ist kein Internet gewesen um mir ein paar Notizen zu machen.
Also eine der Ansicht das ist die Nullnummer. Ihr könnt schon mal abonnieren und gewisse Treue aufbauen indem ihr euch einfach merkt wo es diesen Podcast künftig geben wird auf der anderen Seite wird sie einfach überall geben.
Der Ansicht ist die Nullnummer. Ihr könnt schon mal abonnieren und eine gewisse Treue aufbauen in dem ihr euch einfach merkt wo es diese Potthast künftig geben wird auf der anderen Seite wird sie überleben.
Ihnen die neuen Zwanziger.
Die neuen Zwanziger die neuen Zwanziger.
Und wir hoffen dass der Mehrwert die Mehrwert Generierung zwischen uns beiden für viele auch Mehrwert generieren.
Wir hoffen dass der Mehrwert die Mehrheit Generierung zwischen uns beiden wird auch mehr.
Bis 2020 würde ich sagen Bis 2020 sind ja nur noch zehn Tage gut rein in die neue Zeit. Bis bald.
Bis 2020 sind ja nur noch fünf Tage rutscht gut rein in die neue Zeit.
Intro/Outro